so Alberto writes in can a main
character have two desires sure but
usually only one wound people often
think that they can where they get
excited about the whole idea of a core
wound which they should because it
really gives you an original character
but when we in real life by the way we
have a dozen wounds right I mean you
know let's talk about mine or not but
everybody has more than one won't sure
but movies and to some extent television
alia more lead or simple okay so you
want to sort of see one big wound but
then yes many simple desires come out of
that you know Tony Soprano had one big
one my mommy hates me
so but a bunch of desires came out of
that you know I love prostitutes love
working a strip club
I love hurting people I love to be
violent you know I love to run things I
love being a boss you know I love being
a dad I like so so you can have many
desires just know that all the desires
come out of the wound and they're often
unhealthy okay
they're often unhealthy desires that's
what you want to see if they were
healthy there'd be no show so especially
in television you get wounded then you
do a lot of unhealthy things and
sometimes your superpower and in
television that's another thing you need
to know usually in television your hero
has a superpower and usually that
superpower especially at the beginning
is being used for wrong reasons bad
purposes for instance Don Draper and Mad
Men has a superpower he's insanely
seductive okay he any seductive as a
womanizer any seductive as an ad man but
it comes from the fact that his mommy
didn't love him right he feels unlovable
so all the things he does he uses his
super power for bad reasons because he's
wounded he seduces women right he he
does ad campaigns for cigarettes and
horrible things
and he's a moral as an ad man because
he's misusing the super power but the
super power came from his wound if he
hadn't been wounded I'm not lovable he
would have never become a great seducer
he wouldn't have needed to so the the
superpower is related to the wound but
the disease but the but the the things
he wants come out of the unhealthy
desires of him trying to make the wound
go away trying to feel better about the
wound every desire is an ability is an
attempt to surprise the the wound to to
to palliate
[Laughter]
you